Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number two
one nine two. David P. Trump's performance
on Saturday at his rally was so bad that I got
way more people angry with me for my coverage
of the rally than normal. Here's one example.
Speaker 7: David Pakman, this is your only friend
from Cleveland, Ohio, a conservative responding to
your pathetic. Performance last night, did you get
a pink slip for your performance last night?
Speaker 1: No, I mean, I'm in charge,
who's going to fire me
Speaker 7: interrupting Trump at your when?
Is that what liberals find entertaining?
Seriously, you earn a paycheck for that. Yes.
You know, David Trump's rallies are censored.
Speaker 1: And no, they're not
Trump's rallies are not censored.
Speaker 7: Are limited. Have limited
exposure because of Big Tech censorship,
Speaker 1: that's completely untrue.
All sorts of right wing YouTube channels
and Facebook pages streamed the rally
live and had hundreds of thousands of viewers
Speaker 7: because they fear the truth. And that's
why I got stuck with you and realize that what a
classless, shameless, ignorant liberal you are.
Speaker 1: Anyway, he goes on for two more
minutes, but the worse Trump's performances are,
the more messages like that I get really, really
quite a trend that we see. We have a great bonus
show for you today. We will talk about who would
stay and fight if Russia invaded the U.S. There's
a new poll and much, much more. Sign up at join
Packman dot com and get instant access to the
world famous bonus show. Much hated by Alex Jones.
Speaker 4: Oh, the bonus show where you want
to make money and everybody else that
makes money to fund themselves is bad.
Speaker 1: I will see you on the bone.
Unidentified: Thank you, Alex.